i'm making this video to respond to some
ordinary gamers
who shouted us out guys we're on the
come up okay we got some fake
channels shouting this out some ordinary
gamers has like two mil subs baby
and he gave us some love so i wanted to
respond to him because he had some
interesting points
and i want to get to that because i have
a lot to say about it
he said look he made a video youtube is
promoting scams and in his video he's
like hey they're policies against
promoting scams but it seems like
youtube's promoting them anyway
and this is my message i want to share
with some ordinary gamers
right here wait youtube is promoting
scams
always has been and we're gonna get into
some examples
into this video into some favoritism for
advertisers over creators i mean
creators think we're the lifeblood of
this uh
this platform but we're not it's the
advertisers
and they get crazy preferential
treatment even
the scammy ones we'll get into that but
first let's go back to the office so we
can talk about
um our shout out welcome back here we
have mudahar shouting us out here
let's go to my one of my favorite
channels which is coffeezilla you may
don't worry guys i won't let it go to my
head hey remember this channel from the
time we covered the youtube boxing
situation regarding a fellow brethren of
mine
friend black tren black's great make
sure you go subscribe to his channel
programmer
well coffeezilla is somebody that
focuses on a lot of these mlm scams
these
great day trading scams and uh
he he's a he's a pretty solid content
creator give him a chance i did i i feel
like um
this is too much it's like watching
yourself get a compliment it's a little
cringy a little bit
but anyway the point is i just i wanted
to say thank you
i got a subscriber bump when he posted
this
a lot of love from his community so
thank you very much i think we have
probably have a lot of audience
overlap he sometimes talks about scam
stuff like this uh
in the community wrongs that need to be
righted but i wanted to say
his point which is basically youtube
doesn't follow their own policies on
scams like
how can these scams be allowed it seems
like they're playing favorites here
the fact that we get strike for that
kind of odd i've literally showed you
all these pyramid schemes they all fall
under the scam section
but how much do you think they're going
to get enforced by youtube none
probably not much at all ladies and
gentlemen this video is already long
enough i want it to have
anyway that's the main point he makes
and i wanted to add to that because a
lot of you guys have not seen
this clip i think i'm the only person on
the internet that seen it because
otherwise
all of you would be talking about it we
actually have definitive testimony from
an advertiser
about the about the favoritism that they
get look at this
this is a clip from a grant cardone
podcast with tai lopez
tai lopez at one point was one of the
biggest advertisers on the platform that
was a non-branded advertiser
and he's going to tell us just the kind
of preferential treatment they get
but i i'm almost the biggest youtube
advertiser maybe
coca-cola or something dude come on
you're not that big
that's what google tells me of non-huge
brands well yeah but i didn't
compare itself to coca-cola you can't do
that well i'll tell you this google
sends two people to my house
i got two or four reps that fly down
from san francisco yeah
uh excuse me you have two to four reps
dude hey i want attention all
youtubers okay attention all youtubers
how many of you guys have got had
youtube fly out
reps to your house to make sure that
everything's okay
ty you're gonna keep spinning with us
right what can we do for you ty
i mean i don't know any other youtuber
besides maybe
maybe ethan klein that gets this kind of
love
from the boys upstairs okay because we
just don't
the rest of us creators you're lucky if
you have a rep
that will email you on the full moon of
every month i mean most of us don't even
have that
i had a rep once hey guess where they
are nowhere to be found they left the
company
i had contact for like three days with
google and then they're like
hey we really value you but we're never
gonna respond again that's
the normal creator experience you really
don't have any contact with them and if
you do
it's periodic it's like a telegram
levels of contact
it's like terrible nobody that i've ever
seen has this level of access but that's
what advertisers get
so and so i say am i the biggest and
they go we're not allowed to tell you
but they wink at me yeah
of course they send those guys out and
of course they're not gonna shut down
tai lopez he's keeping the wheels
turning as sick as it is
get rich quick schemes pyramid schemes
they make
a lot of money and i want to show you
the kind of crazy reasoning they use to
stay
within google compliance okay in their
videos they make these insane claims
but they stay legal by making these
ridiculous disclaimers all the way at
the bottom and i'm going to show you
exactly what i mean
because by if the world were just what
i'm about to show you would be
considered
a scam or a get rich quick opportunity
which is technically
against google's uh terms of service
what's going on guys robbie here and how
would you like to learn how to make a
thousand dollars a day online
a thousand dollars a day online now as a
quick reminder
get rich quick schemes are supposedly
against youtube's policies
remember get rich quick schemes are
against
their policies you're not allowed to do
this but consider a spam
deceptive practices and scams policies
and yet this is what i got advertised
on google today and you could get it too
you probably got one on this video
in this training and in this video i'm
going to share with you my three-step
method
on how i've been able to do that guys as
a matter of fact it doesn't matter if
you have any experience whatsoever
it doesn't matter how old you are this
hey you can get rich
even if you're young if you're like 12
years old if you're you know
any age no experience required this is
the classic get rich quick scheme
a thousand dollars a day nothing
necessary right no you don't need
anything
now let me show you how they get around
it because there's a little
there's an abracadabra magic words that
allows you
to promote scams on youtube ready you go
to his webpage here we go
number one clickbank affiliate in the
world free training how you can
affiliate
generate a thousand dollars a day or
more and then you go
all the way to the bottom look at that
all the way at the bottom
and there here's the abracadabra word
it's so tiny i have to go to like a
thousand percent
zoom to even read it in summary you
understand that we make
absolutely no guarantees regarding
income
as a result of applying this information
hey
are you insane did you not see your own
video what does it say at the very top
of this video
what's going on guys robbie here and how
would you like to learn how to make a
thousand dollars a day online
we make no assurance representation or
promise regarding uh it doesn't matter
how old you are this system and this
training will work for you guys
or promise regarding future as and if
you start following it today you can
make a thousand dollars a day online
oops we make no assurance representation
or promise regarding future earnings
you can make a thousand dollars a day
online and that my friends is my
response to some ordinary gamers
right here right here youtube knows what
they're doing
they know what's paying the bills
they know what's generating the revenue
here
tai lopez was their number one non-like
gigantic brand like coca-cola advertiser
right these guys are paying the big
bucks and that's what's preventing
youtube from
doing a mega crackdown on youtube i
probably spent
i would say 25 to 30
maybe 45 million bucks as creators you
and i
we mess up oops dude you're lucky if you
get a strike
your channel could just get removed
we've seen that happen but if a scammer
says you can make a thousand dollars a
day online with no experience
no kind of training from any age oh
don't worry hey did you not see his fine
print
did you not see his fine print on page
seven of the include disclosure did i
click on the earnings disclaimer
oops anyway guys don't i'm a little
heated i'm gonna be honest
but that i wanted to make a quick
response not so quick response to some
more near gamers thanks for the shout
out
thanks for the follows guys and um
as always and don't forget to smash like
and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
comes along